everybody we're here with George Clooney
and you've been in so many iconic movies
and TV shows and we just would love to
share fun facts if there's a fly on the
wall moment it's called behind the
scenes
The Golden Girls yeah
uh Bea Arthur was the funniest person in
the world they were all hysterically
funny but B Arthur really made me laugh
she was filthy filthy funny oh my girl
oh filthy but great they could get away
with stuff that if those women were 30
they could never have said on network
television you know but they could do
anything they wanted and and they were
just they'd get away with it it was so
much fun though that was a fun show to
work on I mean it just Betty White was a
godsend
out of sight
first really good movie first really
good movie you felt you were a part of
[Music]
I just saw Danny DeVito he did yeah I
left the list of people I had slept with
because I was trying to count
um at his house oh that's not good he'd
go what's this list which would be like
hey what's his list
no I got trouble with him at a
restaurant here in New York about 15
years ago and we were having a couple of
drinks both of us were promoting a
different film we had like a couple of
glasses of wine and then the guy comes
out goes you want some limoncello and
I'm like no no no no yeah and he goes
what are you doing tomorrow and I go I'm
doing Regis and Kelly I go what are you
doing and he goes I'm doing the view and
he says all right you got to say my name
and I got to say your name and I was
like okay so out comes this limoncello
and I'm just dumping it in the plant you
know I guess in danger yeah the next
morning I go do uh Regis and Kelly and I
go last night was with Danny DeVito you
know and then I come home and I turn on
the TV and the view is on and Danny
comes they go ladies up Danny and he
comes walking out in the same clothes he
was wearing the night before
and you can Google it because it's very
true he comes out drunk as you could be
sits on like Rosie O'Donnell's lap and
it's like telling a story and like
they're like you're cracked and he goes
I'm crunk I was out last night with
George Clooney
[Applause]
and I get the blame
yeah oh my God ER oh yeah
yeah there they are I guess it was the
friendship I have with all of them or
that I continue I've had Tony Edwards at
the house in Italy a couple three weeks
ago and uh he and mayor came I I'm still
really close with Juliana and Noah and
Eric they're they're really good friends
and so I feel that was a a job of a
lifetime you know and it changed my
career it did that makes people so happy
to know because we all want to believe
that you know and then when you find out
it's true you're like oh I I thought so
so fun okay I have to throw this out
there because I still see the wave in my
head kind of on a very too regular basis
The Perfect Storm it's part of why I'm
still scared of boats you know I was
really scared of boats well not like
near land
okay but out in the water you're scared
that deep open water I mean what that
movie like screwed me up I remember we
were standing on the dock I was standing
up on the boat on the dock and you're
with uh Dirk Diggler yes yeah Mark and I
were standing up there and we had all of
these giant rubber swordfish because
Wolfgang Peterson he's a big animal
rights guy you know and so there's all
these rubber swordfish at Great expense
they made he was like we'll do the fake
fish and all these protesters like a
couple hundred of them come storming
down on the dock one you know shame on
you shame on you and Mark and I were
sitting up on the on the dock and I just
go they're rubber and then it was like
ah I go the rubber the fish there oh and
then they turn around
okay The Descendants uh Shailene
probably I actually just saw her this
summer in Italy too she's a real amazing
young woman and uh and working with
Alexander Payne who I just love as a
director and he's a friend so I there
was nothing but great memories of that
well speaking of I mean good night and
good luck is one of the most beautiful
important poetic extraordinary outside
of the box nobody was doing anything
like that that is a masterpiece how did
you come up with the concept to approach
it that way I was upset with the lack of
uh journalists the fourth estate not
questioning the lead up to the Iraq War
and I felt like the other three estates
had sort of given up you know and so we
were on our way there and no one was
asking questions and when these other
when when the executive branch or the
judicial branch and the legislative
branch don't stand up the fourth estate
you know the the Press has to and they
didn't and so I just started looking
back at times trying to find a moment
when uh when those same branches were
failing and the fourth estate stood up
and that was when Murrow took on
McCarthy and so I wrote it about that it
was a lot of a lot of great books that
were already written about it because
they were all journalists so you could
be pretty accurate about it it was a
fight I wanted to pick and it was
something you know I'm immensely proud
of but it was a really fun thing to do
too what was the conversation also when
you said I want to make this the most
beautiful film ever in black and white
yeah they didn't want that of course
well you know black and White's a hard
thing to get people to do but you know
we only know those characters and black
and white and we were going to use it
was funny we used actual footage of
McCarthy you know Joe McCarthy in in the
film it's all just him and then when we
tested it everyone says you know what do
you like the actors do you like the
actors I think the guy playing McCarthy
was terrible and I was like yeah it was
McCarthy that's see that's the kind of
tidbit that really will rock my world as
we only ever saw them in black and white
so I want to keep it you know not
anachronistic and authentic to that
moment that's so intelligent intelligent
was cheaper
okay the last thing I have to hit it's
very personal for me and Joe Tudy
Natalie Blair
[Applause]
in love with you before ER like that was
the most formative show for me growing
up that was like yes Facts of Life was
everything to me I never missed an
episode I was obsessed and when you came
in that was so much fun I came in late
it was like the seventh year yeah I like
it was like Edna's Edibles or like they
had a store at that point they were out
of the dorm room like they were all they
were growing up yeah exactly sure what
was it like on the set of Facts of Life
it was amazing listen
um it really was fun I mean they really
are they're really wonderful young at
the time ladies uh and we were sort of
that switch over I was there look at
this I was there for one year with Mrs
Garrett and then the next year with
Cloris Leachman taking over that's right
and Cloris was crazy fun I heard she is
kind of like the be Arthur with the
wicked wicked sense of humor crazy crazy
like she would like lift up her dress
and be like look George I'd be like okay
but it's just other jokes look at that
look at those hair now that's two
mullets by the way
we have the same hair I think
I think like when I saw the picture I
was like oh my God they went to both
went to Super well there was a super cut
there was a sale and look at this
McKenzie
they're all great they're still gray
they're really nice young women uh Nancy
and I stayed pretty close over the years
you have these two beautiful children
Alexander and Emma you have this
beautiful career you have this very very
meaningful uh just so needed Beautiful
film coming out ticket to Paradise
you're an activist you have great
friends you've lived an extraordinary
life
I was a two-time sexiest man alive yeah
I mean what more
[Applause]
Missing Link is there one thing yes AARP
Sexiest Man still alive
[Applause]
and they were like you have to be 50. I
was like well I'm coming at you in two
years just like wheel me out
sexy
every dream you've ever had come true
there's no one more deserving of it than
you George Clooney you are why we love
you congratulations on your show
congratulations on all your success I
was so excited to have this conversation
with you I love our history I love you
as a human you're as good as it gets and
thank you for gracing us with your
presence today
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]